bonjour à tous bienvenue dans europe
hebdo votre rendez vous de l'actualité
européenne à moins d'un mois maintenant
du scrutin nous avons décidé de nous
mettre à l'heure de la campagne entouré
de journalistes étrangers et de
politologues
nous allons décrypter ces enjeux dans
cette émission focus sur la grande
bretagne un discours anti-immigration
des relents populistes et largement anti
européen depuis quelques mois nigel
farrage député européen et leader du
parti ukip est l'homme qui monte sur la
scène politique il veut faire deux font
partie la première force d'angleterre et
bouscule les formations traditionnelles
un scénario qui n'est pas sans rappeler
celui de marine le pen en france ou de
geert wilders aux pays-bas mais d'abord
l'actualité david cameron esquisse les
contours de son europe
herman van rompuy fait son bilan et les
provocations de silvio berlusconi
simon barbarie pose la question de la
semaine l'europe est-elle le bouc
émissaire idéal
c'est la faute à l'europe
à quelques semaines du scrutin certains
partis conservateurs ont trouvé leurs
arguments de campagne pour rassurer
leurs électeurs le premier ministre
britannique david cameron a donné le ton
dans la presse il réaffirme sa volonté
de proposer un référendum de sortie de
l'union avant la fin de l'année 2017
et puis tant qu'à faire son pays ne
participera jamais à l'euro ne fera
jamais partie de l'espace schengen
rejettent l'autorité de la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme et
contre le projet de défense européenne
bref david cameron est européen mais il
se soigne et surprise jean claude
juncker le candidat conservateur à la
présidence de la commission se dit prêt
à discuter des spécificités britannique
de son côté le président du conseil
européen herman von rompuy a la
conscience tranquille
le désenchantement à l'égard des
instances européennes n'est pas liée à
la gestion de la crise financière et de
toute façon ils l'affirment bruxelles ça
n'existe pas
l'europe c'est la somme des décisions
collectives des états membres pas mal ça
pour motiver les électeurs mais bien
mieux
silvio berlusconi s'est attaqué à martin
schultz nos candidats socialistes de la
présidence de la commission l'ex
cavaliers réexplique pour les allemands
les camps de concentration n'ont jamais
existé mais il est où le rapport
et pendant ce temps en france le parti
europe ecologie les verts déplorent une
campagne européenne trop courte pour
vanter l'europe positive
c'est sûr que là on ne va pas leur
donner tort alors l'union européenne un
bouc émissaire idéal et pour évoquer
cette épineuse question l'europe bouc
émissaire idéal j'ai trois invités avec
moi bonjour
amandine crespy vous êtes chercheuse
spécialiste des questions européennes et
professeur à l'ulb l'université libre de
bruxelles bonjour merci d'être avec nous
salman tyler vous êtes rédacteur en chef
adjoint de european voice qui est un
journal qu'on connaît bien et lorenzo
consoli vous êtes journaliste italien
est correspondant pour le team news
quand on voit un petit peu cette
actualité qui est un petit peu chargé
qu'est ce que vous ressentez est ce
qu'on doit dire aujourd'hui que l'europe
est toujours le bouc émissaire des pays
des états et des politiques ça aille mal
oui je pense qu'il y a beaucoup de
problèmes qui sont un prix attribué à
l'europe
quand on voit la campagne
on britannique on en était pour
l'instant c'est beaucoup basé sur
l'immigration avec ok oui les a beaucoup
plu gomme qui sont attribués leur pouls
et c'est vrai alors ce syndrome c'est la
faute à bruxelles comment est-ce que
vous l'expliquer lorenzo moi je dois
dire que c'est cette fois ci il est vrai
que c'est la faute à bruxelles de la
crise c'est rizla la crise qui a
commencé en europe en 2010 pas la crise
qui a commencé aux états unis d'amérique
en 2008 mais la crise qui concerne les
ronds-points 2010 c'est c'est la faute à
bruxelles ce sont les décisions qui ont
été prises complètement mauvais au
niveau de la gestion de la de la zone
euro qui ont créé une crise ils ont
infligé à une crise à l'europe qui
n'étaient pas nécessaires ce sont des
mauvais choix c'est la photo
oui absolument il faut aussi dire que
c'est la crise la pire que l'union
européenne ait jamais connu depuis la
fondation même de la delà de la
communauté européenne et à mon avis je
suis là depuis très longtemps la
responsabilité et la éclair et c'était
ces élections sont différent de tous les
autres élections qu'on avait jusqu'à
présent parce que pour la première fois
on peut vraiment dire qui a été
responsable cette crise les gens qui
sont au pouvoir
quand je perds ma ne vendrons pas il dit
par exemple que ce désenchantement
vis-à-vis de l'europe n'est pas lié à
l'action des gouvernements respectifs et
et de bruxelles en gros il manque
il y la réalité il nie la réalité il dit
une chose qui est absolument le
contraire de ses quais sous les yeux de
tout le monde c'est à dire que c'est
effectivement ce sont les choix de
bruxelles qui ont créé une situation
très difficile pour beaucoup de gens
dont surtout dans le sud de l'europe et
alimenter la montée des populismes la
montée des situations la montée des
mouvements contre l'europe et on est
dans cette situation aujourd'hui dans
laquelle il faut même peut-être se poser
la question s'il ne faut pas prévoir le
héros pour sauver l'europe c'est
peut-être ça la l'alternative de
laquelle il faudra discuter mais pendant
ces élections et surtout après amandine
crespy comment est ce qu'on explique que
le président du conseil et a fortiori la
plupart des instances européennes et la
représentants sont aveuglés à ce point
sur les raisons du désenchantement
vis-à-vis de l'europe
je sais pas s'ils sont aveugles et je
pense qu'il ya une conscience des
problèmes mais c'est vrai qu'un certain
nombre de questions on a l'impression
sont un petit peu tabou et on peut être
d'accord ou pas avec les conceptions
britannique
mais en lançant le débat et en
revendiquant l'organisation d'un
référendum dans son pays
david cameron a le mérite de mettre les
pieds dans le plat et de pointer du
doigt un certain nombre de problèmes qui
sont des problèmes de fond et c'est vrai
qu'un certain nombre de responsables
institutionnels ou même deux leaders
nationaux on a l'impression ne veulent
pas aujourd'hui parler de ces questions
fondamentales qui sont est ce que
l'europe doit tête plus qu'un grand
marché les britanniques ont leur avis
sur la question est ce qu'il fallait
s'engager dans la monnaie unique
avec toutes les obligations et
l'interdépendance que cela a créé donc
maintenant c'est une question à laquelle
évidemment les membres
les pays membres de la zone euro doit
faire face est ce que le modèle de
développement économique à l'intérieur
de l'union européenne
ça doit être la mobilité des
travailleurs jans la mobilité des
travailleurs ça renvoie aussi à une
concurrence intra-européenne c'est à
dire que globalement on l'a vu avec le
débat sur la directive sur le
détachement des travailleurs
un roumain coûtera de toute façon moins
cher qu'un anglais a fortiori moins cher
qu'un français et ça crée des disparités
si je puis dire dans l'est dans les pays
d'accueil
voilà c'est la question
du modèle de développement économique
basé sur la concurrence où chaque pays
va exploiter et c'est bien normal ses
points forts donc ça explique aussi ça
concerne la mobilité des travailleurs
mais ça concerne aussi par exemple la
question de politique industrielle
la question de savoir si on peut avoir d
industrie automobile forte dans chaque
pays d agriculture forte dans chaque
pays etc etc alors le problème c'est que
la campagne n'a pas véritablement
démarrer ou du moins à peine
où en est l'état de la campagne saayman
en angleterre en ce moment est ce que
ces débats intéresse un petit peu les
anglais oui mais on ne peut pas dire que
c'est suivi dans les grands médias en
fait se construit c'est cela fait c'est
les le les sondages pour l'équipe
le uk aussi alors quelques minutes oui
ce qui est très important mais je dois
de dans les médias grand public il n'y a
pas beaucoup de rap otage ce les
élections européennes sauf sur du québec
que ce qui se passe avec nos radios
faraj lorenzo on a vu silvio berlusconi
encore faire de la provocation dans ce
dans ce petit sujet qu'est ce qu'il pèse
encore en italie de moins en moins en
fait dans cette même
émission dans laquelle il a dit c'est
foutaise on a en a pour la première fois
on a enregistré une baisse de l'écouté
de l'audimat
alors que alors qu'ils parlaient alors
qu'il parlait eh oui donc en fait il y
là il commence à fatiguer un peu légion
avec ses animations ses provocations
accéder là par contre une chose qu'il
faut dire cette phrase sous les aliments
moi je ne crois pas les aliments qui si
on demande aux allées monde ils ne
savent pas qu'ils y aller qu'il ya eu
les champs de concentration nazis je ne
crois pas qu'il a cliqué qu'il qu'il ait
dit ça comme ça parce que parfois il dit
des choses vont s'enfoncer sans trop
pousser mais là ils voulaient intercepté
vraiment le sentiment un thé à la menthe
qui est très fort aujourd'hui dans les
pays du sud de la zone euro et en italie
aussi parce que on voit que là on
considère que la crise a été créée la
crise de la zone euro a été créée par
les mauvaises choix de bruxelles et de
l'union européenne
mais sous vraiment là
l'emprise des jeunes anguilles
d'hégémonie du gouvernement allemand
merck et les chocs et ça c'est quelque
chose qui est très très répandue dans
tous les pays du sud
et c'est une autre question qui
n'existait pas avant c'est à dire pour
la première fois on revoit en europe des
divisions nationales des animosités une
forte critique des des autres pays de
dun pays comme l'allemagne en plus ce
qui est considéré comme un mauvais pays
et j'ai mon il ne mérite pas l'hégémonie
qu'il a au niveau de la zone euro parce
qu'ils ne pensent qu'à ses intérêts
nationaux contre les intérêts généraux
de long un pays peu solidaires alors
depuis quelques mois david cameron est
talonné sur sa droite par nigel farrage
le fantasque leader du you keep le parti
eurosceptique et anti immigrés nous
avons donc voulu savoir comment ça se
passait sur place reportage à londres de
faustine saint-geniès
bienvenue à barking dans la banlieue est
de londres
ce quartier déshérité et le point de
chute de nombreux immigrés notamment les
nouveaux arrivants en provenance
d'europe de l'est
lituaniens hongrois roumains ou encore
bulgare à tel point que désormais un
habitant sur deux dans ce quartier est
étranger un sujet visiblement sensibles
l'immigration est devenue un thème
important qu'est ce que vous en pensez
vous trouvez qu'on en parle trop j'ai
pas mal de choses à faire il faut
vraiment que j'y aille
désolé les noirs restent avec les noirs
les asiatiques avec les asiatiques
vous voyez quoi avant ce n'était pas
comme ça avant les gens se mélangent et
c'est devenu vraiment dur vous savez il
ya beaucoup d'étrangers viennent
s'installer ici
du coup nous sommes devenus une minorité
mon père ils sont plus nombreux
c'est eux la majorité aujourd'hui si les
autorités peuvent réguler l'immigration
internationale avec l'espace schengen
elles n'ont plus la maîtrise des flux
intra européen
ce thème de l'immigration européenne
à ses pieds de biche ont ces derniers
mois dans le débat public au royaume-uni
pays du multiculturalisme et si le sujet
prend une telle ampleur
après avoir été tabou pendant des années
c'est à cause de la bête électorale de
l'ukip ce parti eurosceptique et anti
immigration qui doit beaucoup à son
leader le charismatique nigel farrage
nous devons contrôler l'immigration
nous devons choisir les gens nous
l'avions rencontré en octobre dernier
nous devons avoir une politique
d'immigration qui répondent à nos
besoins des gens qui n'est pas de casier
judiciaire pas de maladies graves et des
compétences rapporté un homme politique
atypique dans le paysage anglais ce qui
séduit tant masse l'électorat populaire
c'est un homme politique extraordinaire
fragile il a une vraie touche de de
populiste il est il et il parle et parle
une langue simple qui parlent une langue
direct c'est par peur de phares âge
qu'eux ils ont été obligés que les
autres partis ont été obligés de
commencer à parler de l'immigration
c'est parce que farrage piquer des votes
surtout du parti conservateur
sous la pression de l'ue qui le
gouvernement a pris des mesures pour
restreindre l'immigration européenne
notamment d'europe de l'est en limitant
par exemple l'accès aux indemnités de
chômage ou à l'allocation logement
les conséquences pourraient être
dramatiques dans certains secteurs comme
le bâtiment ou cette main d'oeuvre est
nécessaire c'est un procédé typique de l
aile droite et actionnaire de mettre sur
le dos des immigrés plutôt que de
regarder l'ensemble du pays
est ce qu'ils ont pu nous apporter si
nous enlevons la main d'oeuvre
européenne des chantiers il faudrait
tout simplement les fermer et cela
aurait un impact sur le secteur entier à
long terme y compris sur les salariés
britanniques
de nombreuses études comme celle de
l'university college of london démontre
l'impact positif de l'immigration
européenne sur l'économie britannique
un message qui a pourtant du mal à
passer dans l'opinion publique
certains mythes ont la vie dure comme
celui des bénéfices touristes traduction
les touristes aux allocations barbara
est responsable d'une ong qui vient en
aide aux migrants d'europe de l'est
arrivé de pologne en 2008 elle a été
confrontée à certains préjugés
on m'a posé la question est ce que tu
viens ici pour voler des emplois j'ai
répondu mais quel genre de travail je
viendrai volé je sais pas femme de
ménage comme si j'étais une femme de
ménage professionnels pourquoi j'irais
voler un travail de femme de ménage et
peu à peu on finit par en rire mais au
début il faut faire avec c'est a priori
désormais barbara se sont intégrés à
londres mais elle redoute que le climat
ne sont venues mme avec les élections
européennes des élections ou l'ukip de
nigel farrage pourrait devenir la
première force politique du pays
saimone le youki première force
politique du pays vous y croyez non
seulement dans le sens que l'on les
élections pour le parlement européen ils
vont peut-être être le parti le plus
soutenu
le dernier sondage indique un dos des 2
31% c ils ont dépassé le travail les
bobs pour la première fois mais ce qu'il
faut je ne veux pas dire que c'était une
force politique dans tout le pays et qui
parle pour l'instant aucun député dans
le dos naïve comme elle est aujourd'hui
l'ajout farrage a pris la décision de ne
pas se présenter pour une sieste dans la
souffrance parce qu'il y a député
conservateur qui c'est démissionner donc
c'est uniquement si l'europe et dans les
parlements européenne qui qu'ils ont
qu'ils influencent et et pour moi ça
indique la fable est ce la faiblesse
relative du parlement européenne parce
que les électeurs peuvent dire je suis
prêt à soutenir équipe parce que je sais
ça change rien c'est leur fiscalité ça
change rien selon l'enseignement ça
change rien soleil les soins de santé et
en tant que le vote dont le parlement
européen on a l'impression qu'à chaque
changement go beaucoup dans les grands
sujets croissance emploi les électeurs
vont être prêts à encore fait des votes
protestent et pour moi équipe vote
proteste surtout contre les partis
établis parce que tous les partis ont
pouvoir soit consommateurs soient
sociaux démocrates ont dû imposer une
sorte d'autorité ils ont dû redresser
les finances publiques
et c'est pour ça dans un accès de faible
croissance économique de 2 sur des taux
de chômage élevés que les électeurs
sont tentés par des albanais avaient
pâti de crise vous êtes d'accord on en
crée spi c'est un vote de crise ce
recours comme ça c'est pas uniquement en
angleterre oui bien sur la meme chose on
a la même chose en france avec nationale
on a le pays bas garçon à la ligue du
nord en italie on à l'aube dorée en
grèce
c'est malheureusement la liste s'allonge
oui bon les partis populistes et
extrémistes
évidemment profite toujours des crises
et ils font leurs leur commerce
électoral en période de crise
pourquoi parce qu'ils pointent du doigt
les vrais problèmes semblent y apporter
les réponses de bon sens donc qui
parlent un langage de faciliter
d'ailleurs comme ça que nigel fin je les
appelle ce sont des réponses de bon sens
à des problématiques voilà le bon sens
sur des problèmes compliqués et
malheureusement les partis en place de
gouvernements n'apporte bien souvent pas
beaucoup de réponses et même pas
beaucoup de discours sur ces questions
là et revient sur l'immigration par
exemple il ya une attitude parfois qui
consiste à nier les réalités ce qui est
contre-productif
on peut palier que le royaume uni a été
particulièrement concernés avec voilà
plus d'un million personnes qui sont
arrivées
ça change des choix politiques faits ça
a été un choix en 2004 ou le royaume uni
a choisi de ne pas mettre de restriction
à l'arrivée donc au moment de
l'élargissement à l'europe centrale et
orientale et l'a de nouveau il faut
s'interroger pourquoi pourquoi est-ce
que l'immigration est bénéfique pour
l'économie
parce que c'est un réservoir de main
d'oeuvre peu cher dans des secteurs
l'horeca la construction où on manque de
main d'oeuvre est donc là il faut
s'interroger aussi a pas une forme de
dumping aussi sur la main d'oeuvre le
fait d'aller chercher cette immigration
qui est souvent moins bien payés
effectivement il ya un problème de
dumping et de contournement des règles
à la fois national et surtout européenne
qui parfois ne sont pas suffisamment
efficaces mais de nouveau le jumping est
possible avant tout parce que les états
ne conduisent pas de contrôle et les
états ne font pas de contrôle parce que
la main d'oeuvre bon marché ça booste
l'économie donc il faut se poser les
questions à tous les niveaux alors il ya
un autre débat qui est celui celui ci
plus institutionnel lorenzo il est
question d'une alliance entre le front
national le parti de la liberté de geert
wilders aux pays bas peut être la ligue
du nord nigel farage a refusé de
participer à une alliance avec marine le
pen
qu'est ce qu'elle est le risque pour le
parlement européen de voir arriver un
groupe d'une centaine de députés
europhobes anti européen il faut dire en
tout cas ce n'est pas la première fois
que les forces interrompre un essai de
former un groupe soudé un groupe commun
disons paneuropéenne il faut dire aussi
que dans le parlement européen si on
n'est pas dans ce groupe si on est dans
les médias on ne pèse rien il y à des
groupes eurosceptiques mais un groupe de
populiste du robben jamais pour six
parce que dans ce populisme un terreau
veine il y à beaucoup un élément des
nationalismes qui fait que c'est
difficile de mettre ensemble des
nationalismes différents pour ces
énoncés impliquent du nord
le parti de marine le pen et les autres
qui ont essayé de créer cette griffe qui
vont essayer dé près ses goûts je crois
qu'ils ont dit qu'ils réussiront à le
faire mais ils ne vont pas avoir chez
eux tous le tous les partis populistes
parce que justement nous quitte ne veut
pas participer on sait pas ce qu'il va
faire après et il y à d'autres groupes
qui ne vont pas participé non plus
peut-être il y aura quelques quelques
élus qui sera convaincu parce qu'il faut
quand même avoir cette les députés élus
des sept pays au moins pour pouvoir
former un gouvernement européenne alors
quelqu'un qui à mon avis ne va surtout
pas participer à ce groupe là c'est le
cgri le beau son mouvement le moment de
grill qui créditaient aujourd'hui de 24
pour son devoir en italie pour les
élections au 27 ans sondage d'hier c'est
qu'il veut dire entre qu'il aura entre
20 et 25 députés
alors qu'est ce qu'il va faire grillo
grillo c'est un populisme complètement
différent des autres mon avis parce
qu'il ya beaucoup plus d'éléments de
gauche que d'éléments de de droite il
est un peu arty migration mais pour le
reste il est fortement engagé sur les
questions environnementales et là à mon
avis il y à une alliance naturelle qui
se fera avec les avec les verts et les
fédéralistes ce que sont les îles n'est
pas fédéraliste comme les verts mais il
faut dire aussi qu'il est proche des
positions de six places poussée qui
concerne la gauche radicale pour ce qui
concerne l'euro c'est-à-dire contre
l'euro en tant que tel ou tel qu'il a
été gérée aujourd'hui mais pas contre
l'europe
landing respect ce qui a véritablement
un risque de blocage des institutions
européennes 6
la droite populiste ou les droites
nationalistes
il ya plusieurs noms arrivent à
constituer un groupe non un blocage
complet certainement pas on se dirige
donc comme ça a été dit probablement
vers deux voire trois groupes de droite
eurosceptique populiste groupes
différents
donc ce qui est sûr c'est que la
proportion de ces forces politiques là
va augmenter de manière assez
considérable au sein du parlement
européen et surtout ai je fait écho à ce
qui vient d'être dit sur les textes
particuliers même à l'intérieur d'un
même groupe
si on avait un groupe réunissant par
exemple geert wilders le fp autrichien
et marine le pen
il y a très certainement un grand nombre
de textes sur lesquels ils auraient bien
du mal à se mettre d'accord
notamment parce que marine le pen a joué
sur la corde sensible sociale française
qui est à l'opposé des conceptions
libérales d'autres populistes européens
alors lors du débat qui a été organisé
par euronews il ya quelques jours les
différents représentants des partis
politiques ont tenu à formuler une
réponse sur l'extrême droite en europe
on les écoute
nous devons avoir un dialogue avec les
citoyens sur des solutions concrètes
ce que je veux faire c'est montrer
qu'ils n'ont pas de solution ils m'ont
causé bouc émissaire mais n'ont jamais
proposé une seule solution
tous ces défis auxquels nous sommes
confrontés aujourd'hui une besoin d'une
solution européenne
nous devons nous attaquer aux craintes
de la population nous devons prendre au
sérieux les craintes des associations
il faut faire la différence entre ceux
qui critiquent en partie pour des
raisons justifiées l'intégration
européenne et ceux qui sont contre
l'intégration européenne foje je ne
débattrai pas avec ce ne sont pas des
membres de la famille avec lesquels je
dois dialoguer je suis contre eux ats je
pense que c'est vraiment dangereux que
les partis démocratiques ne doivent en
aucun cas prendre cette solution de
facilité quelle utilisation des slogans
de bas étage nous devrions toujours être
fort et ne pas avoir peur de faire face
à l'extrême droite
simone est ce qu'il ya un manque de
réponse globale de la part des partis
classiques si je puis dire à l'extrême
droite on les sent un petit peu
désemparé oui oui en fait c'est très
difficile parce que dans une période de
crise économique
on a dû redresser les finances publiques
et le taux de chômage est très élevé et
donc les solutions 13e populiste et
facile des partis d'extrême droite et on
dit européen centré sont très efficaces
ce qui fait vraiment se relancer la
croissance en europe et ça c'est très
difficile comme comme monsieur jean
claude juncker a dit hier c'est pas les
raisons politiques qui créent des
emplois c'est les entreprises donc il
faut créer une europe compétitive qui
doit concurrencer maintenant avec l'asie
avec avec le brésil avec tous les autres
pays ça c'est ça c'est difficile à faire
qu'est ce que vous pensez à maman crespy
de ses réponses d
deux partis classiques si je puis dire
mais je crois que il doit ya voir où il
va y avoir une évolution générationnel
et j'ai l'impression que parfois les
dirigeants peut-être de l'ancienne
génération comme jean claude juncker ont
tendance à continuer à utiliser la
l'ancienne stratégie qui consiste à
stigmatiser la diaboliser en disant
qu'ils ne font pas vraiment partie du
vrai jeu politique etc
je crois qu'on est arrivé véritablement
au bout de cette stratégie là et qu'il
faut maintenant une réponse à la fois
sur les questions particulières comme
l'immigration le chômage est à la fois
sur le projet d'ensemble de l'europe ça
suffit plus de dire que les populistes
n'ont pas de réponse parce que en
prenant dans bien des cas le retour à
l'autonomie nationale éventuellement la
sortie de la zone euro etc
ce sont eux qui proposent les seules
alternatives aujourd'hui là où bien
souvent les citoyens en écoutant
côte-à-côte martin schulz jean claude
juncker et d'y faire obstacle ne
comprennent pas très bien où se situent
de conflit fondamental et les projets
diffa sachant qu'en plus en l'europe
on est plutôt dans la culture du
consensus à 28 forcément donc tout ceci
en fait créé une forme de flou sur eux
encore plus il y a
une bon résultat pour les partis
populistes les participants au grand
collection ensemble lorenzo vous allez
avoir le dernier mot
est ce que vous êtes confiant sur ses
prochaines élections je crois que on a
pour la première fois vraiment un des
élections européennes qui vont
déterminer la survie du projet européen
où son déclin et c'est la première fois
que ça arrive parce que cette crise est
une crise vraiment grave
gravissime et je ne sais pas si les gens
sont vraiment conscients de ça mais
j'espère que le débat dans la peau les
élections européennes arrive à focaliser
ce point ce sont des choix très
importante soit on continue avec la même
héros qu'on a connu jusqu'à présent et
qui a échoué
qui est il elle a échoué elle a échoué
dans ses institutions
elle a échoué dans ses choix de
politique économique et la celle achevée
dans sa distance par rapport aux
citoyens elle n'a pas réussi à
comprendre le drame de certains citoyens
de certains citoyens dans l'ensemble
citoyens qui sont surtout dans les pays
du sud de l'europe et les délais ni une
europe des créditeurs c'est à 10 ce sont
les créditeurs qui dicte la loi est
encore économique c'est l'europe des
banques et pas l'europe des citoyens
oui c'est le sait l'europe des
créditeurs encore plus que des banques
oui c'était bon mais surtout des
créditeurs selon les créditeurs sais pas
s'ils sont pas seulement les banques
c'est aussi des états créditeurs alors
il faut sortir de là il faut il faut
avoir une europe qui soit vraiment
l'europe des citoyens qui revient à
faire les intérêts générant des citoyens
et la c1 très important qui sera le
prochain président de la commission et
les chocs et la commission va faire bon
écoute et merci à tous les trois d'avoir
participé avec moi aujourd'hui à ce
décryptage
nous on se retrouve la semaine prochaine
sur la chaîne parlementaire bonne suite
de programmes
j'en étais